pas parler dans une seconde à véronique
hivon qui a fait partie de cette
commission
spéciale sur l'évolution de la loi
concernant la fin de vie mais d'abord
david gêne-t-il et nous explique les
grandes lignes de la rade des
recommandations de la commission
elle célèbre un rapport qui pourrait
leur faciliter l'accès à l'aide médicale
à mourir
à 42 ans sandra de montigny souffre déjà
d'une forme génétique de la maladie
d'alzheimer j'ai une pensée pour mon
peuple je
me soucie
son père a décliné longtemps avant de
décéder elle refuse de vivre la même
chose pour moi c'est clair depuis
longtemps que je veux pas vers la fin de
vie d'une maladie d'alzheimer précoce
génétique elle se réjouit des
recommandations de la commission
spéciale qui s'est penché sur les soins
de fin de vie elle propose qu'on
permette de formuler une demande
anticipée d'être médicale à mourir je
veux pas avoir quelqu'un qui vont
nourrir trois fois par jour parce que
sinon je mens jamais que quelqu'un qui
ait besoin de ma compagne aux toilettes
tout le temps la demande pourrait être
formulée à l'avance par une personne
apte mais qui est menacé par une maladie
mortelle et irréversible comme
l'alzheimer haute à ma mère veut une
belle fin de vie autant que moi si gm
par exemple en occuper à temps plein en
plus de savoir qu'elle sait pas ce qu a
désiré de dépendre des autres ok ça
rajoute quelque chose d'encore plus
dramatique je suis vraiment content de
voir ça c'est une bonne idée mais par
contre évidemment jeté un peu lichun un
proche désigné d'avant serait chargée
d'en déclencher l'application ce qui
pourrait être complexe dans bien des
familles même si les cochons sauvages
pour la personne
que j'ai un rhume et n'insultent à la
commission parlementaire recommande
cependant de ne pas élargir l'aide
médicale à mourir aux personnes
souffrant de problèmes de santé mentale
les troubles mentaux juste ni aucun
témoignage de personnes
atteintes ou de proches qui sont venus
nous plaidé pour ça que mes maîtres jean
pierre ménard pense que ce serait une
injustice pour ces patients les temps de
jeu imprudemment
est invariable aux patients cependant il
semble y avoir un consensus politique
pour élargir la médicale à mourir en ce
qui a trait aux maladies dégénératives
sandra profite donc de son nouveau
statut de grand mère mais elle sent
chaque jour que la maladie progresse
elle se réjouit donc de savoir que
québec veut légiférer rapidement pour
élargir l'accès à l'aide médicale a mûri
ce que je souhaite c'est en effet
pouvoir partir
d'in main alimente avec le sourire aux
lèvres un belge et une belle vie ici
david gêne-t-il et radio-canada mourir
bonsoir véronique hivon bonsoir monsieur
roy membre de la commission spéciale sur
cette question de mourir dans la dignité
alors on est rendu là pour vous ça
semble clair n'être là que pour les
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer par
exemple on est rendus locke qu'on peut
choisir
avec une demande anticipée de mourir
avant la fin
naturelle si je peux dire oui je pense
qu'on est on est vraiment rendu là c'est
une question
de respect de la personne de l'autonomie
de sa dignité c'est une question de
compassion aussi je pense qu'on connaît
tous des gens qui ont vécu des fins de
vie agonisante longue dans un état
grabataire extrêmement difficile
totalement dépendants et souffrent et je
pense qu'on ne souhaite pas se surtout
quand les gens de leur propre arbitres
après un diagnostic en sachant ce qui
les attend font une demande de manière
complètement libre et éclairé oui je
pense qu'on est rendu là et qui parce
que ça va être plus difficile à gérer
que les premières étapes qu'on a connus
parce que l'on parle d'une fin de vie
douloureuse on est vraiment en fin de
vie là qui va déterminer que c'est le
moment c'est un fait c'est une fille
c'est parce que moi par exemple je
reçois un diagnostic à 78 ans
d'alzheimer et je dis moi je ne veux pas
être une charge je ne veux pas et quand
je n'aurai quand je n'aurai est ce que
je mets des facteurs quand je ne
reconnais très plus personne quand je
pourrai plus manger et qui décident du
moment vous avez raison de dire que
c'est très complexe c'est pour ça que
vraiment nous retourner chaque pierre on
a débattu énormément dans une
fantastique commission transpartisane où
on était le jeu devrait comme humain
représentants des humains et non pas
comme humain représentant un parti ça
fait toute une différence et en fait ce
n'est pas un tiers qui va décider pour
vous c'est vous qui allez décider pour
vous en inscrivant la vence les
manifestations de la maladie
l'évolution de la maladie qui fait que
selon vous vous allez avoir atteint un
stade de non retour où la déchéance va
étaient les souffrances vont est telle
que c'est la chose que vous souhaiteriez
ensuite évidemment vous allez désigner
un tiers de confiance c'est une balise
importante que l'on recommande le tiers
de confiance n'est pas là pour consentir
à votre place pour décider à votre place
est juste là pour agiter le petit
drapeau auprès de l'équipe médicale pour
dire mon père ma mère mon ami mon
conjoint il avait écrit il y a deux ans
il y a trois ans que rendu là ils
voudraient considéré l'année du kala
moor et par la suite ça se fait pas
comme ça le cpo vous l'avez demandé vous
l'obtenez c'est l'équipe médicale va
évaluer les circonstances et vont
évaluer le respect des critères qui sont
les mêmes qu'à l'heure actuelle donc
déclin avant serrés vers ces maladies
incurables et bien sûr présence de
souffrances constantes et inapaisables
donc c'est pas du tout un bar ouvert
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
balisé et quand vous avez discuté de ça
j'imagine que des gens qui ont soulevé
l'idée que quand on signe quelque chose
avec toute notre tête dans un état x de
santé on n'est pas nécessairement la
même personne dans un état y quatre ans
plus tard et que quatre ans plus tard il
ya peut-être des petites joies de la
musique un sourire de sa conjointe et
ses qui font que peut-être on voudrait
plus partir aussi vite s comment on fait
pour baliser tout ça tellement si vous
saviez le nombre de fois que j'ai posées
précisément à peu près dans ces mots là
la question à des experts à des groupes
qui sont venus se faire entendre
vous mettez le doigt sur quelque chose
qui est fondamental c'est à dire que on
peut s'imaginer avoir des souffrances de
manière anticipée mais qui ne se
concrétiseront pas qu'on va être rendu
au stade qu'on avait prévu première des
balises qui est fondamental c'est
d'avoir un diagnostic vous pouvez pas à
50 ans prévoit que si un jour à 80 ans
vous avez la maladie d'alzheimer vous
voudriez avoir la médicale à mourir il
faut que vous soyez dans une trajectoire
vous êtes encore apte mais vous avez un
diagnostic de maladie
neurocognitives dégénérative vous êtes
entourés de votre médecin vous écrivez
votre demande avec votre médecin en
sachant ce qui s'en vient en sachant ce
qui peut arriver dans la maladie les
souffrances qui peuvent arriver mais
évidemment rendu au stade où vous pouvez
avoir prévu que vous voudriez avoir
laniscat amour et ça se peut que vous ne
souffriez pas comme vous l'aviez
anticipé il ya une experte qui lui a
donné le cas par exemple d'une dalle qui
avait dit moi quand je reconnaîtrais
plus mes proches mais rendue au moment
elle reconnaissait plus son mari mais
elle le trouvait extraordinairement
charmant et à chaque jour elle veut
reconquérir on sent qu'il ne souffrait
pas donc il faut que les critères soient
aussi rempli au moment de la négociation
d'un prêt à mourir donc si aucune
souffrance si y'a pas de secret si a pas
de crispation s'il ya pas d re ans il
pourra pas y avoir d'amis triés à mourir
je pense pas que les médecins non plus
très confortable dans les messages qu'on
a eue il ya eu des avis contradictoires
mais la majorité donc de cette
concomitance qui est importante ce que
j'ai prévu mais ce qui est aussi le fait
la situation au moment réel de
l'administration oui parce qu'on la
perspective change
moi j'ai vu mon père changé et puis
vient ce n'était pas le même en mai
enfin bref c'est complexe et vous le
reconnaissez il faut que ça se fasse
avec beaucoup de doigté de souplesse
aussi si la famille ici des enfants sont
pas d'accord sur le moment ça peut créer
aussi détention oui bah en fait c'est la
même chose je voudrais là dessus que la
situation actuelle c'est à dire qu'il ya
des gens qui demandent l'aide médicale à
mourir tout à fait apte et conscients
enfin une vie c'est pas toute la famille
qui est nécessairement sur la même
longueur d'onde ce sont des questions
très complexes on invite toujours les ja
évidemment au dialogue dans leur famille
dans leur entourage mais là c'est la
même chose la personne va désigner un
tiers qui va accepter cette charge le
qui est très lourde de conséquences il
va devoir l'accepter par écrit donc ce
dialogue il va devoir avoir eu lieu et
donc elle excède pas de consentir à sa
place alexis d'agiter le drapeau pour
que la volonté de la personne soient
respectées je pense que c'est
fondamental ça avance dans un certain
nombre de pays s'avance même au canada
cette question là un peu partout les
sondages montrent que les gens sont
d'accord pour la plupart vous voyez ça
être opérationnaliser quand vous même ou
surtout ne déposera par unanime qui est
très fort parce que encore une fois il
fait suite à des mois de consultation
il est très fort parce que beaucoup
d'acceptabilité sociale plus que de
l'accepter social c'est une demande la
population je peux vous le dire pour
donner une conférence sur le sujet donc
aujourd'hui c'est entre les mains
maintenant du gouvernement du québec le
ministre dubé dit qu'il en prenait acte
qu'il allait regarder le tout nous c'est
clair on le dit aujourd'hui on espère le
tous ensemble la présidente le vice
président les membres du comité
directeur tous les membres de la
commission que ça va avoir des suites
dans les plus brefs délais bon tout cas
et si le fait aussi que ça soit unanime
tous les partis comme vous dites ça
avait été le cas la dernière fois où on
sent là qu'on est plus du tout dans la
joute partisane ont les dents des choses
existentielle c'est le cas de le dire
quelques secondes j'en ai pas parlé
parce que vous l'avez écarter les gens
qui souffrent de maladies mentales vous
êtes sort on n'ouvre pas la porte pour
pour eux on a débattu énormément aussi
la raison ultime pour laquelle on n'a
pas le confort le niveau de précaution
et de prudence qui est requis selon nous
c'est qu'on ne sent pas le consensus au
sein même de la classe médical sur la
question de la durabilité de lille vers
sibilité de la maladie mentale des
troubles mentaux est aussi
l'acceptabilité sociale et je dirais
l'espèce des pulsions social qui doit
nous pousser un et pas du tout à la même
hauteur que ce soit dans ce camp est
reçu comme commentaire comme témoignage
comme comme un sondage aussi donc il
faut il faut tenir compte de ça je pense
que le principe de précaution était
était fondamental dans ce cas ci et puis
encore je pense beaucoup de débats à
faire sur cette question là véronique
hivon merci beaucoup merci pour votre
éclairage votre réflexion merci merci de
votre intérêt à voir